c'est la plus petite planète de notre
système solaire mais aussi l'une des
moins connus mercure est même si elle
est très proche de notre soleil est
encore loin d'avoir livré tous ses
secrets
pourtant en 1974
la première sonde est envoyé vers
mercure l'expédition marine ordis est
une première marine heures 10 a continué
son chemin ou direction un petit caillou
qui tiendrait dans l'océan atlantique
marine heures 10 est parti en direction
de mercure le but
cartographier la surface de mercure et
ça y est les premiers clichés arrive sur
terre la mission est une réussite et
tout de suite
un rapprochement est fait avec sa
jumelle la planète mars mercure tout
près du soleil ressemble à mars sur ces
clichés de marine heures dix clichés
noir et blanc que nous avons
volontairement ou j car la planète
apparaît roja mais la petite planète
n'est clairement pas la priorité des
scientifiques
il faudra attendre 2004 soit trente ans
après marine heures 10 pour qu'une sonde
fasse de nouveau route vers mercure la
mission messenger l'odyssée de messenger
a débuté ce matin la sonde spatiale est
parti pour un voyage de huit ans mais la
planète reste la mal aimée de notre
système solaire
pourtant quand mercure passe entre le
soleil et la terre
tout le monde sort son télescope il vaut
mieux ne pas la rater car le phénomène
reste très rare
l'alignement n'est parfait qu'une fois
par décennie il est précisément 13h12 à
paris et ce petit disque noir c'est
mercure vue d'un satellite qui entame
son passage devant le soleil 280 x plus
gros qu'elle seulement deux missions 45
ans alors pourquoi ce désintérêt pour
mercure ce chasseur d'éclipsés nous
donner la réponse en 2003 et peu de sens
qui l'ont photographié aucune ne s'est
posée dessus doit pas plutôt été a
intéressé par envoyer des cendres aux
endroits où ils espéraient trouver de la
vie où des traces de vie mais la mission
bepi colombo va permettre de nous en
apprendre un peu plus sur la planète la
moins explorés de notre système solaire
le satellite analysera notamment la
structure interne de mercure ainsi que
son interaction avec le soleil
[Musique]